je pourrais te faire tout ce que je
comme quoi n'importe quoi comme quoi
comme ce qui me ferait envie qu'est ce
qui te ferait envie tu as envie de jouer
au scrabble
ouais c'est à ça que je pensais
et si je te laisser ici que je reviens
te chercher demain matin je serais
vraiment furax
oui je serai en pad cij est la caméra
sur toi que je reviens demain matin ça
ferait une projection d'enfer t'imagines
ce serait pour tous au mur avec toi qui
frissonnent jean pagé et les bébés
imaginales c'était ville disparaît bien
parler ses coûts monsieur jay style
ouais tu bonne nuit
arrête à temps c'est pas drôle hazan
salut à demain jeu we had marc cherry
adam
bah